hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen fall is officially here
and you know a lot of you guys are
looking for some seasonal recipe
inspiration so today a partner with base
Sal who sponsored this video to share
three plant-based sides featuring my
fall BFF sweet potatoes everyone has
that food that reminds them that fall is
coming I know a lot of my fellow
millennial women would probably say
pumpkin spice latte fair I mean when I
smell that combination of artificial
pumpkin flavoring steamed milk and
coffee I want to throw my bomber jacket
on too but the fall food that I actually
look forward to most is sweet potatoes
here in Canada saying goodbye the summer
means saying goodbye to well most of
life's pleasures corn berries patio
drinks being able to leave the house
without dressing like the Michelin Man
you know but what we do get out of our
annual trade sees is sweet potatoes now
around this time of year I admittedly
eat a lot of sweet potatoes so much so
that a lot of you guys have pointed out
that my hands are orange worth it
definitely worth it but they're high in
fiber and antioxidants and naturally low
in fat plus they are gluten free dairy
free and vegan they're also super easy
to whip up for a weeknight while also
being a classic staple ingredient for
all of the fall and winter holidays I
mean sweet potato casserole sign me up
honestly the only thing that's
disappointing about sweet potatoes is
their emoji which I really do not
believe embodies their greatness am i
right but let's be real the way I was
raised
sweet potatoes like all potatoes are
generally treated with some serious
buttery love fare but to keep these
recipes at vegan-friendly
I'm using base L vegan which has no
artificial preservatives colors or
flavors is low in saturated fat and as a
source of omega-3 fatty acids it's also
completely lactose free and gluten free
so it's an easy plant-based butter swap
so good for spreading on toast and also
a must for these three sweet potato
sides let's do this first up is my mash
to pull a sweet potatoes
I place my sweet potatoes on a lined
baking sheet and prick them with a fork
then I bake for one hour at 350 degrees
until very soft I scoop out the insides
and I mix in some base elf vegan cashew
milk chipotle pepper some extra adobo
sauce and some salt to taste then I
serve the warm
tapa cilantro and enjoy next up is my
pecan pie sweet potato wedges in a bowl
I combine some melted base l vegan maple
syrup lemon juice and pumpkin pie spice
[Music]
arrange the sweet potatoes cut into
wedges on a baking sheet so that they're
not touching then I generously brush the
maple mixture onto the sweet potatoes
and bake them for about 20 minutes then
I season with a generous pinch of fleur
de sel and crushed pecans enjoy finally
my orange Chinese five-spice twice baked
potatoes
I place my potatoes on a lined baking
sheet and pierce them with a fork then I
bake them for one hour at 305 degrees
until very soft I carefully cut an
opening into the potato lengthwise but
not cut all the way through and I gently
scoop the insights out into a bowl then
I add the base L vegan orange zest and
juice some Chinese five-spice and some
salt and I mash until smooth then I pack
the mixture back into the potato skins
and transfer to the oven for another 15
minutes or so until lightly browned on
top
finally I garnish with some crushed
cashews toasted sesame seeds and
scallions
enjoy so whether you're serving these
sweet potato sides as part of your
holiday spread or you're gonna serve
them alongside some quickie tofu steaks
on a random Tuesday night
I hope these recipes have inspired some
great easy plant-based ways to get your
sweet potato fix a big thank you again
to Bay cell for sponsoring this video
if you guys love these sweet potato
recipes please give this video a thumbs
up leave me a comment below with some of
your favorite fall staple recipes
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]